so because I'm just trying to illustrate
it to jog your memory let's go for a
nice simple example okay so suppose they
asked me to solve sine X is ha and
they'll provide a domain until we get to
general solution which is a couple of
years ago okay
so for instance radians okay
so domain supply in radians to make sure
you put your balancer in radians if
you're the kind of person who's still
struggling a little bit to get your
brain into radians mode and you're sort
of instinct at the moment is to convert
to degrees in your head solve it in
degrees and then at the last step put it
back into radians can I tell you now is
the time to stop what will happen is
you'll be like okay I'm solving
questions so much slower I'm even
getting something wrong because I'm not
familiar with radians guess what's the
only way to get familiar with radians
just do the work in that from the get-go
okay so there are two ways to solve is
we can do this graphically we can do it
by quadrants
okay so I'll show you buddy I'm gonna
start with graphically okay sine X what
does it look like in this domain and
this is the hole here at 0 to PI okay so
it's gonna look like this now because
I'm solving what I'm really asked to
solve is this okay so it doesn't matter
if my graph looks awful it just needs to
be good enough so I can get an idea of
what the answers will be now tell me
what's the range off so what's the -1 in
the top is good so therefore if I'm
trying to solve sine X is equal to 1/2
get your alright hope where half is okay
and Papa way through now there are my
two solutions okay so even if it's a
pretty awful drawing if it's like if it
of a Glee resembles a sine curve you've
already got a general idea of where your
1/2 solutions are going to be okay now
then you want to think about your exact
sign x equals R cough what's the exact
value in radians let's see it's good
so does that look like it could be pilot
six yeah matches because this is about
PI sure enough that does look like about
the sixth row and then using symmetry
you can see to get this solution I've
got PI on six that way so you get this
solution I'll have to go final six the
other way so PI minus PI and six that
gives you so I can say on the ground
that's a common X is equal to PI on six
five six it's not and because it can't
be both okay now let's come over to this
approach of quadrants you still take the
same approach at the beginning when you
think about your exact values right so
you would say sine X is equal to you
might actually say sine alpha is equal
to 1/2 so I'm trying to think of what's
my my base angle okay so that'll be six
okay and then you draw your quadrants
are right now what are these letters
mean they're referring to which
functions are positive in which
quadrants okay so all the functions are
positive in this quadrant sine is
positive in this quadrant and you get
the idea so PI and six was that look
like that's going to be this first angle
yeah and then you come back to what you
originally wrote okay and this value is
shows that sine is positive right so I
can't be in either these quadrants to
use so I ignore them okay so then I have
to say in this quadrant watch plan six
look like it always comes from the
horizontal okay so plan sees that way
and you can see it's analogous to
looking at the graph and go in to the
left a little bit okay so plan six going
up a bit the actual answer
the actual angle that's the answer I'm
after is this obtuse angle right and
that's the 5.6 that I got before okay so
from there I can see therefore
okay okay um do you have to draw the
quadrants no you can say as sine alpha
is positive therefore first and second
quadrants they're kind of like
equivalent statements okay
however most people when they trying to
work out with these Agra's are they draw
the quadrants anyway and it's the same
yeah all right now for a question like
this because it's so it's so standard
right like it's a simple example I think
you would be fine coming down to here
okay but we throw in a negative or
something unfamiliar or if it's squared
sine squared x equals equals 1/2 so
you're gonna get 1 over 2 plus or minus
1 or 2 etc you're really not doing your
song a favor if you ignore this step
because you're just going to open
yourself up to forget solutions or pick
them or quadrants or something like that
and of course the other guy is coming
marxism I would expect this yeah okay
but here's the thing right if you get
these wrong and that's all you've
written it's game over
we're Alice if you've got this and this
is wrong I can still pay you something
because I they sort of had the right
graph
they just made some fundamental error
that makes it in the end I mean the
general is I am taking shortcuts tends
not to be a shortcut usually okay now
just personally I prefer the graphical
method way over the corners method he's
my reasoning um people usually don't
wide the graphical method because they
like graphing takes forever okay but you
kind of get away from graphing you must
be good at graphing if you're gonna be
an extension one student then you've
you're not gonna get you're not gonna
escape route okay so you might as well
get good at that and secondly I find it
more reliable right when you want to put
in a half you're not going to mistake
which quadrants it is because like bang
bang it's not like oops it must be this
one like in line doesn't even go there
okay where is this one sometimes I
forget which one I'm going or you know
I'll do something silly like put that
there and then think uh you know the
angles the angles this one instead of
the other way around
I find that confusing okay but either
method is totally valid usually Shevin
when you find more comfortable and
whichever is faster for you